[Music]
the truth is you don't have anything to
give that you don't have so you have to
keep your own self full that's your job
you know one of my daughter's is here
today from Oprah Winfrey Leadership
Academy stand up today so everybody can
see it
[Applause]
[Music]
you're gonna end your first year soon oh
my god its first year I say to the my
girls all of the time that your real
work is to figure out where your power
base is and to work on the alignment of
your personality your gifts that you
have to give with the real reason why
you're here that's that's the number one
thing you have to do is to work on
yourself and to fill your self up and
keep your cup full keep yourself full
now I used to be afraid of that I used
to be afraid particularly from people
who say oh she's that she's so full of
herself she's so close or so and now I
embrace it I considered a compliment
that I am full of myself because you
only when you're full I'm full I'm
overflowing my cup runneth over
I have so much I have so much to offer
and so much to give and I am not afraid
of honoring myself you know it's
miraculous when you think about it first
of all for me my father and mother never
married they had sex one time underneath
an oak tree because she was wearing a
poodle skirt in 1953 and my dad to this
day says I want to know what's under
that skirt because what I won't know
you want to know what was under the
skirt they didn't really have a
relationship she wanted one but you know
he went under the skirt and then that
was it
and one time under the oak tree BAM
Renaissance woman that's why I know my
life is bigger than that my life has to
be bigger as yours is bigger than a
moment then that poodle skirt it's much
bigger the design the the the reason why
I'm here is much bigger than oh I think
I want to see what's under that so the
ability to take care of that to honor
that to honor yourself and that which is
greater than yourself
that which was the reason for your being
here that that there's no selflessness
in that because only through that do you
have the ability to offer yourself your
whole self your full expression of who
you are to the rest of the world
[Music]